Vsauce Kevin here the toothbrush dates
back to at least the ancient Babylonians
and Egyptians who frayed the end of a
stick to scrub their teeth but in the
15th century the Chinese invented
something closer to the modern
toothbrush using bristles from pigs
necks attached to a bone or bamboo
handle pig or horsehair was used for
toothbrushes until nylon was invented in
1938 ancient toothpaste recipes have
ranged from the ashes of burnt mice
heads and eggshells to more abrasive
crushed bone and oyster shell
concoctions of Greeks and Romans and the
1800s toothpaste was actually a powder
containing soap and chalk and it wasn't
until 1890 that tubes with paste came
into the picture
but unfortunately the tubes were often
made of lead which leaked into the
toothpaste and in case you still got a
cavity Ozark folklore held the belief
that carrying the jawbone of a donkey in
your teeth and walking backwards could
cure a toothache the Chinese have been
making a form of toilet paper since at
least the second century by mixing
mulberry bark hemp and rags with water
mashed into a pulp then pressed and hung
to dry in the Sun but other cultures
have wiped with everything from sticks
Moss and corn cobs to pebbles carried in
a special bag or a sponge on a stick
dipped in a bucket of salt water when
New Yorker Joseph Getty invented aloe
infused sheets of Manila hemp to prevent
hemorrhoids in 1857 the public scoffed
at the idea because why pay for wiping
paper when they already had old
newspapers TP eventually caught on
because of the advent of the flush
toilet and people needing a paper that
navigated plumbing and pages from the
Sears Roebuck catalog just clogged the
pipes but there was a time where you
didn't flush urine you collected it to
wage wars urine contains saltpeter which
along with charcoal and sulfur creates
gunpowder outhouses and cities had trays
under the seats that were pulled out
from behind and nightsoil collectors
came by and empty the contents
into a wagon where it was delivered to
concrete tanks to recover the saltpeter
during the Civil War in the u.s. while
the men of the South were off fighting
the women were doing their part by
collecting their urine a contribution
immortalized in poems what could make a
Yankee soldier sadder than dodging
bullets fired by a pretty woman's
bladder and as always thanks for
watching